[Music]
because we look at the attributes that
really make something rest on the in
destructure layer our education system
really does make those attributes
however there seems to be an erosion of
the structure level in our society we're
not investing as much money as we used
to at that level and sphere commerce
level seems to have overtaken so much of
our society that could be at the root of
some of the erosion of our education
system the buildings are big just like
bridges they're out of date and they're
starting to leak bags so we may need to
reconciliation or at least recommit to
trying to build it back up as if it were
an infrastructure I think recognizing
that but that layer is pushing the layer
below and generating change not simply
getting in the way
is a is an interesting idea a powerful
it gets so mired in a politics and so
mired in the obstacles and so mired in
the resistance to change that this
exercise to me frees me up to kind of
think about longer time frames and new
strategies and patience and the efficacy
and usefulness of messiness I start to
think of these different paces and
different motives and different values
as opportunities we get frustrated a lot
of times that education is slow to
change and that if we actually work
through the pace layers you can see the
different areas of where you can get
quick change and education more at the
top you know around fashion lovers if
you want to do real impact you have to
be in it for the long haul I think this
is such a necessary corrective because
even if we don't need to short-term
thick short term we do just by the
nature of our work and how far we focus
and all of our conversations about
school that how schools should change
what matters we tend to focus on you
know what is effectively one layer and
one set of values and wish the others
didn't exist and I think the realization
that all this isn't work all the time
and all this is necessary this is a part
of a through a functional system of the
evolution of civilization
is actually quite liberating